[Music]
yeah some guy called over here but
doctor he's looking for a driver
you interested I am NOT a medical doctor
I'm a musician
I'm about to embark on a concert to work
in the deep south what other experience
do you have
public relations do you foresee any
issues in working for a black man you
and the deep south
literally problems promise me you're
gonna write me or water the crumbs
Tommy dental smile but I've never had
fried chicken of my life you people love
the fried chicken you have a very narrow
assessment of me Tony
Yeah right I'm good we'll be interacting
with some of the wealthiest people in
the country it is my feeling that your
addiction wolf could use some finessing
my balls because you can do better mr.
bat along the Lord I saw dr. Shirley
play the piano it's like a genius I
think come on got the throne enough to
get grease on my blankie this gentleman
says that I'm not permitted to dine here
I'm afraid not
how does he smile and shake their hands
like that
because it takes courage to change
people's hearts what are you doing
blood Leon dear Dolores sometimes you
remind me of a house you know this is
pathetic right but this time the
distance between us is breaking my
spirit falling in love with you was the
easiest thing I have ever done
PS kiss the kids that's like clinging a
cowbell at the end of Shostakovich is
seven that's good it's perfect oh never
win with violence the only win you
maintain your dignity people you mr.
bigshot doing concert for rich people so
if I'm not black enough and if I'm not
white enough whatever anyone could sound
like baked over
[Music]
your music will you do oh you can do
that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what do we do about the bones we do this
pick it up Tony squirrels would eat it
anyway pick it up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you